INCLUDING THE OWNER OF THE     H
INCLUDING THE OWNER OF THE     E
HEN" WHO CONTINUED TO PROTEST
THEIR PRESENCE OUTSIDE OF THAT
RESTAURANT.
>> Bret: >> Bret: THE SAN
>> Bret: >> Bret: THE SAE
>> Bret: >> Bret: THE SAS
>> Bret: >> Bret: THE SAT
IS JUST THE LATEST IN A SERIES
OF DECORUM BUSTING MOVES THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN UNTHINKABLE A
GENERATION OR TWO AGO.
OVER THE WEEKEND, CALIFORNIA
PLACES.
MOMENTS AGO SHE HELD A NEWS
CONFERENCE ON CAPITOL HILL TO
INSIST THAT SHE NEVER CALLED FOR
ANY VIOLENCE.
>> TRUMP IS THE ONE WHO IS
CREATING THE LIES, TRYING TO
HAVE PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT I
TALKED ABOUT HARMING PEOPLE.
THERE IS NOWHERE IN MY
STATEMENT, ANYTIME, ANYPLACE,
STENTS DOWN THE CONSENTS.
BUT PROTEST INSTABILITY.
PROTEST IS ABOUT PEACEFUL
RESISTANCE TO THE KIND OF
ACTIONS THAT WE ARE EXPERIENCING
FROM THIS PRESIDENT.
>> Bret: AGAIN, THAT MOMENTS
AGO ON CAPITOL HILL.
THE RISING TIDE IN POLITICS AND
WHETHER ANY END IS IN SIGHT.
>> Reporter: IN THE WINDOW OF
"THE RED HEN" RESTAURANT, MARTIN
LUTHER
MARTIN LUTHER KING JR.'S WORDS
ARE FRAMED.
WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY SARAH SANDERS TO LEAVE
SIDING TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
POLICIES.
SANDERS COMPLIED.
AFTER AN EMPLOYEE OF THE
RESTAURANT POSTED ABOUT THE
INCIDENT, SANDERS TWEETED ABOUT
WILKINSON SAYING HER ACTIONS A F
WILKINSON SAYING HER ACTIONS A R
MORE ABOUT HER THAN ME.
SHE TOLD "THE WASHINGTON POST"
THAT SHE'S NOT A HUGE FAN OF
CONFRONTATION BUT, THIS IS PART
OF DEMOCRACY.
FOR OTHERS, THE BOOTING
IT FOLLOWS A WEEK IN WHICH
MEMBERS OF THE CONGRESSIONAL
CAUCUS HECKLED THE PRESIDENT.
AND A CONGRESSIONAL INTERN
HURLED A F-BOMB AT MR. TRUMP.
THE SAME WEEK KIRSTJEN NIELSEN
WAS SHOUTED OUT OF A D.C.
RESTAURANT BY AGGRESSIVE
HECKLERS.
THEY SHOWED UP OUTSIDE OF HER
TOWNHOME, ALSO.
OUT AT THE MOVIES IN THE FACE OF
A SIMILARLY CONFRONTATIONAL MOB.
>> IF SHE WANTS PEOPLE TO
INCITING VIOLENCE.
>> THAT WHILE CONGRESSWOMAN
MAXINE WALTERS CALLED ON HER
SUPPORTERS TO STEP UP THE
RESTAURANT OR GAS STATION, YOU
GET OUT AND CREATE A CROWD AND
PUSH BACK ON THEM AND TELL THEM
THEY ARE NOT WELCOME ANYMORE,
ANYWHERE.
>> THE NEXT MOVE IS ON
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES.
IF SHE STARTS TO FEEL THE HEAT
A DEEP FAR, THAT'S HOW YOU FIX
THESE THINGS.
>> THAT'S WITH THE SENATE
MINORITY LEADER DID TODAY.
>> NO ONE SHOULD CALL FOR THE
HARASSMENT OF POLITICAL
OPPONENTS.
THAT'S NOT RIGHT, THAT'S NOT
AMERICAN.
>> HOUSE LEADER NANCY PELOSI
PARTLY DID THAT, NAMING THE
PRESIDENT.
SHE TWEETED, TRUMPS DAILY LACK
OF STABILITY HAS CONDITIONED
RESPONSE IS PREDICTABLE BUT
UNACCEPTABLE.
AND HE FIRED BACK WITH THIS
SWEET, CONGRESSWOMAN NEXT THING
WATERS, AN EXTRAORDINARILY LOW
IQ PERSON HAS COME TOGETHER WITH
NANCY PELOSI AND CALLED FOR HARM
TO SUPPORTERS.
BE CAREFUL WHAT YOU WISH FOR,
MAX.
AND YOU SAW IN THAT LATE
AFTERNOON PRESS CONFERENCE HELD
MAXINE WATERS BLAMED THE
PRESIDENT FOR THAT VIOLENT
RHETORIC AND TOOK NO RESPONSIBLE
DEPORTED.
IT WOULD BE REASONABLE TO INFER
THAT SHE WAS FORCED INTO THAT
LATE AFTERNOON PRESS CONFERENCE
BY THAT TWEET FROM PELOSI ON THE
HOUSE SIDE AND REMARKS BY